they come out and they cleverly redefine  the Cambridge Dictionary definition of  woman now it means man also and  Merriam-Webster has followed suit and uh  and and what do we do we say okay well  you got your 2022 dictionary well I got  my 2012 dictionary and my and now we're  gonna have a battle of the dictionary  definitions but it just doesn't matter I  mean to your point Matt and to the heart  of your movie the answer to what is a  woman is not some stupid definition  that's right every dictionary the answer  to what is a woman is a woman's a woman  and you know what it is and shut up just  shut up you know what a woman is and a  woman is she's she's the kind of person  it's not a man that's what a woman is  and we all know it and that will be true  no matter what these editors put in  whatever dumb dictionary they come out